lexie kaufman
loves disney
loves sparkly
stuffs and things doesn't like a lot of
attention
oddly
so that's kind of how i attribute lexie
kaufman to alexa bliss i become her i'm
not me i become this character and this
persona
and
that's what i find most fun about
[Music]
oh it god
[Applause]
so i watched wwe growing up it was the
thing that my family did on monday
nights we'd watch monday night raw
then i did a lot of athletic stuff
growing up i did gymnastics cheer
kickboxing softball track and then after
high school i went into bodybuilding
after college
and after i got my pro card i didn't
really want to do it anymore and my
trainer said well wwe is having tryouts
i know you used to watch it maybe that's
something you could do
and so i
went online submitted a video didn't
think anything would come of it and i
would i earned a tryout from that and
once i tried out i was signed
and
i remember having
my first match ever in fort pierce
florida on my 22nd birthday everyone's
still trying to figure out what this
alexa bliss is all about
certainly a metamorphosis of sorts
oh
alexa bliss has gone through a lot of
different phases when i first debuted it
was a pixie
disney-ish
tinkerbell-ish character i came out i
wore tutus i blew glitter
then it transitioned into
the high school mean girl
and the one that everyone hated to love
and loved to hate
it wasn't until
it was a year ago it turned me into a
darker character but this has been
probably the most fun character
i've done
because there's no boundaries to it
sometimes you have to trust the process
getting ready for a match
it's a lot of mental preparation there's
a lot of physical preparation
crossbody i thought that with my
athletic background that
anything we did in wwe would kind of be
an easy transition but it is not no
matter what you cannot physically
prepare your body for what we do in the
ring which is why you have to train at
nxt for so many years
until it becomes second nature so now
when we're in a ring everything that we
do kind of our body naturally
falls flat on its back when it's not
supposed to so everything has become
second nature in that sense
[Applause]
so it's a lot of mental preparation and
a lot of what we do is based on crowd
interaction and reaction so a lot of
times we're changing things up to get
the reaction that we need from the
audience and then it's instant feedback
oh and it's alexa bliss running to the
cover
and she gets the victory we have to
always be able to adjust on the fly and
you know still tell the story that we're
trying to tell
while
dealing with a live audience as well so
it's a lot of mental prep
recovery after a match
is um
not fun
well your body
goes through a lot in the ring and we do
beat up our bodies you know
it's very the physicality of what we do
is very real so part of that is making
sure that you're resting you're
recovering you're doing everything that
you need to do to make sure that your
body is ready for your next match
whether it's massage
stretching lifting working out um i take
a lot of epsom salt baths
it helps with sore muscles never has
been like that but yeah it's not too bad
i always drink a lot of coffee but i
don't think that's really a pre-show
ritual i don't know i pace a lot just
trying to get more into character each
time i pace
because by time you go through the
curtain you have to be full-on in that
character she's the smackdown women's
champion
alexa bliss we have pay-per-views every
month but wrestlemania is summerslam
those are our biggest
biggest pay-per-views that we have our
biggest shows and it's a lot of pressure
because it's usually our biggest
audiences and a lot of eyes on us half
the year we pretty much build up to this
one
moment and these are kind of where it's
coming to a head
so any trade secrets you're willing to
share
big lashes and setting spray that would
be you're right big lashes and setting
spray make sure it doesn't rub off in
the ring yeah
a lot of pressure a lot of nerves but it
always works out so amazingly and is so
great especially when the audience is
there and you feel the energy of the
crowd
the bravery
each division has our own champion we
each have our own title and we all
strive to
be the holders of those titles it's kind
of like you're the the face of that
division at that time we also have a
women's tag division which you they have
titles as well
[Music]
most surprising thing people know about
me
everything is really public i love
animals
i used to have a pig he recently passed
but i had a pig i want to open an animal
rescue one day no one knows that but
that's a goal of mine
and congratulations on your engagement
oh
hell
ryan's super supportive he
watches every monday night raw he'll be
here tonight um yeah and he he comes to
as many shows as he can and you know he
loves it and he thinks it's so fun we
met because there was a rumor that we
were dating and we didn't know each
other yet so ms called ryan he was like
oh i heard you're linked to alexa bliss
and he's like what's alexa bliss i don't
know what that is and then i get a call
and they're like hey we heard you you're
dating ryan and i was like i don't know
who that is and
we actually just started talking that
way and then we became amazing friends
and that turned into the most incredible
relationship and
now we're engaged so it worked out for
the best here's what's crazy so
not to get morbid but
i never really put two and two together
of ryan's music when i was younger i
suffered from eating disorders and i was
hospitalized from them and my friend
aaron who would come and stay with me
every day at the hospital was obsessed
with ryan
obsessed and she would always play true
when i was in the hospital i've waited
all my life to cross this line so it's
just kind of funny like
full circle
moment that i would always listen to
true with her and i didn't really put
two and two together that it was his
music until
after we met
[Applause]
did we interrupt things
if i wasn't in this industry
i don't know that's tough because i went
to school for diet after having my
eating disorder so i don't know if i'd
be working at an eating disorder clinic
or if i'd be pursuing acting
because i was very
i'm very introverted as a person i don't
think i would have been able to pursue
acting if it wasn't for breaking out of
my shown wwe
[Music]
wwe will always be home that's always
where i'll be but i would love to you
know
see what happens if i try to go for
acting and everything like that i've
been working with an acting coach for
the last 10 months and you know
everything that i'm doing right now
character base wise is a lot of acting
and it's a lot of fun um but i would
love to
try that one day if the
cards allow that would definitely be a
passion of mine
but for now wwe's home
[Music]
you